one of the challenges that I face all
the time with some of these students is
anxiety and how I can help them yes see
that they are you know they can do more
than they think and that they're
stronger than they know how would you
articulate or excite when to them oh you
know how I do it I'm doing it I put
pressure on the true answers insecurity
is the seed that creates all these
issues and so I'm trying to figure out
why didn't build self-esteem who didn't
build self-esteem and the reason I bring
up mom is like Jesus it's such a big
percentage of it mom or dad is like 80
percent of it it's just you know I do
this a lot of fast things listen my dad
listen I don't talk a lot about this
that's whatever my dad my dad my dad I'm
so impressed by him the way my
grandmother parented my dad is
unacceptable that's the only word I can
think of so I'm fascinated by it because
I had the reverse I'm so perfectly
parented by my mother I'm unstoppable I
feel guilty that I'm so emotionally
grounded and strong that's why I'm
giving it to you dead like what do you
think's happening up here I feel guilty
that I have it so good mentally there's
nothing anybody can do to my mental
state it's insane I am so weird guys
like it like nothing hits
it's like am numb and so I go right to
the core I do it when I see it sometimes
I'm like hey you are unbelievable and
you think you're [ __ ]
that's bad we need to talk about this
tell me everything about your childhood
like you know and I just go there and
you know sometimes you get a little
break sometimes but what's really fun is
they start thinking about it and it
changes behavior I get an email every
day that says that they disconnected
from somebody in their inner circle and
for the last six months they were
breathing for the first time in their
lives it is not easy to break up with
your brother it is not easy to break up
with your spouse it's not easy to break
up with your father but that's actually
the binary move if there's a poison of
your life so hey if that's your reality
you need to think because guess what you
have one life and you don't want to be
73 when your parent passes away and
finally start breathing be if that is
not your life you need to drive home
right now and kiss your parents in the
face
[Applause]
[Music]
and